have you ever wondered how the world's
richest people made their money well
let's look at the top ten first up we
have Elon Musk an internet entrepreneur
who then went on to build Tesla and
SpaceX next is Bernard or not he founder
of lvmh third is Jeff Bezos he built
Amazon a company that allows you to
press a button and deliver anything in
the world almost instantaneously next up
is guatemadani his entire family they're
huge in infrastructure and commodities
then we have Bill Gates the founder of
Microsoft that computer software that
almost every computer in the world uses
sixth on the list is Warren Buffett the
owner of Berkshire Hathaway and one of
the greatest capital allocators in
history seven is Larry Ellison who built
Oracle into an absolute Behemoth eighth
is Larry Page the founder of Google
ninth is Mukesh Ambani he's Reliance
Industries they have petrochemicals oil
and gas Telecom and Retail intent is
Sergey Brin the other co-founder of
Google the 10 richest people in the
world show us that you can make money in
any industry you just gotta go big and
you gotta be right